another Wisconsin community is reeling
after the second incident this week
where police shot an armed student on a
high school campus the latest violence
unfolded yesterday morning in Oshkosh
officials say a 16 year old student was
wounded after stabbing a school resource
officer on Monday around 70 miles away
in Waukesha police shot a 17 year old
who they say threatened an officer with
a pellet gun Dean Reynolds has been
following both of these incidents the
first emergency calls from Oshkosh West
High School came shortly after 9:00 a.m.
we'll say a 16 year old student stabbed
a school resource officer in his office
on campus at which time the officer
fired on the student striking student
one time life-saving measures were
provided to both the officer and the
suspect in this incident both were
hospitalized students were evacuated
from school and later reunited with
their parents I actually got a text from
him that said I'm okay he said I have to
stay silent now the police are sweeping
the school
it's the second Wisconsin shooting in
two days involving law enforcement
Monday and Waukesha police say a 17 year
old student pointed this pellet gun at a
fellow student who then went for help
police had limited information about the
suspects motive he was angry he was
angry angry at another student police
say he then threatened a responding
officer and that's when 11 year veteran
sergeant Brady Esser shot the suspect
once in the leg and twice in the arm he
was put in handcuffs as officials
applied tourniquets to stop the bleeding
they later found another pellet gun in
the students backpack there could be
multiple felony charges on this incident
officials confirm that all public
schools here will be closed for the day
for CBS this morning Dean Reynolds
Oshkosh Wisconsin